you told me in the commercial break you
wanted to you brought something yeah I
did
I feel bad I've never done your show
before and you were so good to come and
do the Global Initiative we do for
university students and I feel like a
schmuck I've never done your show before
and you had to come to my neighborhood
to do it yeah I know that you bring that
all up and I'm kind of bitter about it
all I was fine I didn't even really you
know and then you bring it up and now
I'm angry here's what I did I know you
like bobbleheads so I'll be a guest all
the time the great thing about my
bobblehead is you can turn it into a bad
political joke that is every time you
say something you can just cut me on the
head and I'll agree with you everything
yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna put you right
there next to Eisenhower how's that
that's a good thing
yeah different parties but both they
think you know it's funny you know um it
was a different world but in a couple
years ago in this scholars writing of
presidential performance I wasn't hiring
our back-to-back but I always liked him
because he ordered the integration of
Little Rock Central High School he
federalize an asteroid yes yeah and very
impressive figure it was a big deal in
my childhood you know but he he did that
he had to call out Edison and 101st
Airborne Division but he first
nationalized the National Guard to stop
the governor who had blocked nine black
children yes we just celebrated the 60th
anniversary of that yeah eight of them
who still alive
marginal lives and it shaped my whole
life so when the chips were down he
decided he believed in the Constitution
yeah yeah god bless the bill
you